so we're going to start with your full
name uh and then give me your job title
please
yeah my name is rob pastone and i am one
of the
investor owners of keller williams vip
and i am
also a real estate agent rob how hot is
the housing market right now
right now it's blistering it's very hot
a lot of factors
low inventory low interest rates works
out you know
buyers have an opportunity to lock in at
low interest rates at a historic low for
30 years
i mean it's a win-win situation for
everybody so that's why the market is so
hot right who's buying these houses
oh boy a little everything a lot of
people relocating here from california a
lot of investors getting in
it's it's a perfect mix of a lot of
people trying to you know they've
outgrown their home during covid or
maybe downsizing
uh there's a lot of different factors
right now especially people relocating
here from out of state
so what are some of the challenges or
things that people are seeing when
purchasing a home
you know depending on the price point
but you know it
the the tricky thing is is when you're
trying to buy a home right now
some of the sellers that have done
really good things their homes really
really well presented homes are getting
top dollar for the home so that's where
the most competition is
although there is competition across the
field but you start getting into those
lower price points under 400
000 and i can't believe i'm saying that
in las vegas but yeah the competition is
very fierce
do we need cash when purchasing a home
it helps
it helps you know to to a seller right
now
money's money i mean we do everything we
can we write letters we
you know try to portray the buyer in the
best light you know because you know
some people do want their home to go to
a good family
so we try to get lucky as we can but we
we throw every tool in the
in the every trick in the toolbox in
there so tell me some tips what can we
tell our viewers
in terms if they're looking to buy a
home or if they're in right now in the
process of buying a home
don't jump into it without being
educated you know find a good
professional to work with
get yourself if you're financing get
yourself pre-qualified
um work with someone that's got a good
reputation uh
it's just like anything if you're going
to go get surgery from a doctor you're
going to go get a good doctor if you're
going to go to a good cpa
you got to get a good cap it's the same
thing with your real estate agent your
loan officer
make sure they have a good reputation
ask them questions
and do some research and the last
question can we see what
this year can we see what happened in
the year of 2008 can we see a similarity
there will that happen again
yeah you know i hear that question a lot
and i don't believe that's going to
happen again that was a completely
different
trigger that caused that housing
collapse at that point and you know
right now
as we speak right now a lot of
homeowners over the last 10 years have
bought a lot of homes here in las vegas
when it was at its low
so a lot of homeowners in las vegas are
in a very strong equity position so
i don't see another foreclosure crisis
happening can foreclosures happen
sure but i don't see a crisis happening
anytime soon thank you for your time
you're welcome